this morning the reuters news agency is
reporting that lebanese leaders received
a warning last month
about explosive chemicals being stored
in beirut's port
those chemicals detonated in a massive
blast last week
killing more than 160 people days of
anti-government protests have followed
yesterday
the prime minister announced his
government's resignation
mts tayab reports from beirut
it was a literal handing in of a
resignation
but no one here was buying the prime
minister's carefully choreographed show
of humility protesters bitterly
confronted police
for a fourth day protesters say the
resignations are not enough
they want to tear down the system and
build something new
they want a revolution
[Music]
since the enormous explosion a week ago
lebanon's leaders have been
almost invisible helping no one and yet
somehow the mighty fist of the state is
still able to punch back
protesters say the system is rotten to
its core
the prime minister is resigning is that
enough it's definitely not enough
they don't have our trust they don't
have the confidence so they are
illegitimate for us they are not legal
still
lebanon's longest serving leaders whose
negligence protesters say laid waste to
the capital
remain in power and changing the corrupt
political system
born out of the ashes of a bitter
15-year civil war that ended in 1990
that they benefit from so greatly won't
be easy
but world powers say it's what they want
and that the nearly 300 million dollars
they've promised in aid is tied to
political
and economic reforms
[Music]
but will lebanon's ruling class change
for those on the streets of this
shattered city not soon enough
the first u.s military aid flight
arrived last night
but until the government here agrees to
any meaningful reform
it's hard to see how places like this
across beirut
will get the help they so desperately
need anthony
mts tayyip with the turmoil in beirut
thank you